foreign
internet people we are live on the
computer machine I'm Dave Rubin this is
the Reuben report it's time for another
Friday Round Table Extravaganza uh
joining me today is an All-Star panel
host of Viva barneslaw on locals.com
Viva Frye the CEO of prageru Marissa
stripe and the founding partner of craft
Ventures and the co-host of the all in
podcast David sacks Viva Marissa David
welcome to the Reuben report
good morning everyone
glad to be here good to be with you guys
uh let's just dive right into it because
this was a bit of a crazy week between
the Twitter stuff and the state of the
union and much more uh let's start with
these Twitter hearings uh that everybody
was freaking out over it looks like the
Republicans are actually starting to
show some teeth as I've been saying uh
let's start with this video Jim Jordan
grilling yoel Roth he was the former
head of trust and safety over at Twitter
this is during the hearings yesterday
and I believe there's some more hearings
going on today take a look where so we
don't know how many people had security
clearances
Twitter do we know Mr Baker Mr Gaddy and
Miss Gaddy anyone know how many people
on Twitter had a security clearance in
30 days prior to the election
I don't know the answer to that question
Miss Gatti I do not know
Mr Roth you don't know no sir how about
the last one miss navaroli do you know
no I mean it seemed like the offer was a
sort of just hand them out like candy
yeah just wondering who had him
no one knows okay
sax I want to start with you on this one
because obviously you've been helping
Elon during some of this restructuring
uh you were with me when I was in San
Francisco with Elon a couple weeks ago
so you have some Insider insight into
this what I kind of took away from the
whole thing was that it is just an
absolute mess over there that he's
trying to clean up so I'm somewhat
sympathetic a little bit obviously
there's some negligence with these guys
but I am somewhat sympathetic to people
not really knowing what was going on
because it almost seemed like it was
designed that way am I am I being a
little too kind here
well in terms of the issue of security
clearances it this information is this
came out I think during the the year
before Elon bought the company where
there was a um
there is a cyber security expert I think
named Mudge or something who basically
pointed out that their cyber practices
were completely lacks and that they
didn't really have control over their
data and so there was there was a whole
set of Revelations prior to Elon buying
the company about this
um I I'm not quite sure where Jim Jordan
was going with this I assumed that this
is the predicate for something else that
the committee will be looking into
because it wasn't exactly clear how this
line of inquiry fit in with the rest of
the revelations that day so I assume
he's he's setting up something for the
future right so speaking of the future
thing one of the things that I was
saying yesterday when we were covering
this Vivo was that it's one thing to
grill the Twitter people and it is
worthy to find out what they knew and
who they were working with and all of
that stuff but it seems to me at this
point you need to be grilling some
people at the FBI too like those are the
people you can't just blame the guys who
were getting the call and then either
doing you know bad things or not you
have to blame the people that were also
making the call all in the first place
right well this is the point I made I
did a radio appearance yesterday where
you know it's nice that they're grilling
of the execs of Twitter we know what
they did we know what happened we many
of us knew it at the time because we
were paying attention at the time the
issue and what we did not know the
extent of at the time was active
intelligence infiltration and Direction
and so at the time everyone saying okay
look so it's a biased partisan uh
private company it can do it at once and
now we know that that is not the case
anymore whether or not it was bribery
coercion or whatever they were acting at
the uh behest of under the direction of
and having been infiltrated by
intelligence like James Baker is not
just an executive of Twitter some might
regard him as an intelligence mole in
Twitter he's off just to be clear he's a
he's a former general counsel for the
FBI and that basically was also his job
at Twitter he joined who joined the
company five months before the election
it's very curious it would have been
nice for them to ask them the
circumstances around that right and and
Jim Jordan did or no sorry Lauren bobert
uh I believe on Wednesday did mention
that there were at least nine FBI agents
working at Twitter and it's a little
unclear whether they were still working
for the FBI or not but Marissa I'm sure
none of this surprises you because you
guys at Prager you when we talk about
censorship you guys have been in
lawsuits with Google and YouTube before
and been fighting the the algorithmic
tricks and all that stuff for for quite
some time
well I think that's where Jim Jordan was
trying to reach he's trying to figure
out and really highlight to the public
and to Congress how involved these media
companies have been with the government
and this is one of the issues that we
have had when we've sued YouTube and now
we have these issues with newsguard the
answer that we keep getting when we're
experiencing censorship is that these
are free you know these are companies
they are free agents they're allowed to
do whatever they want to do and we keep
highlighting the fact that there is
government intervention it's just we
can't seem to to grasp where it's coming
from and and hopefully these
Congressional hearings but more so more
investigation and I agree we need to
start asking the FBI why are media
companies like mine uh have felt so much
pressure to censor to self-censor uh and
not just self-center when we produce
content about climate or about the
lockdowns I don't call what I call it
the lockdowns why have we been
threatened with being you know basically
you know taken off the internet entirely
and so I think that's they they have
learned how to play this very tricky
game where media companies can't speak
about certain things that the government
doesn't want you to speak about and then
they use these third-party companies to
basically claim that it's it's their
freedom of speech and their free agents
which they're not no they definitely are
not I want to show you another video of
Jim Jordan on the hunter laptop
situation but before we do that David do
you think that Elon knew the level of
the government stuff before he bought
this he clearly had some sense about the
bot problem and some of that other stuff
but is a lot of this just unfolding
right in front of his eyes yeah I don't
think any of us knew about the extent of
government influence and involvement in
social media censorship until the
Twitter files came out
um first of all I don't even think we
knew for sure that shadow Banning was
occurring to the extent it was uh
remember that Twitter Executives denied
for years including under oath that they
were engaging in Shadow Banning that was
something that Jack Dorsey denied at a
congressional hearing with Vegeta yagati
sitting directly behind him yep as his
general counsel that would have been a
nice thing for them I think to go a
little deeper on they asked her in the
hearings about
um you know whether Twitter had engaged
in Shadow Banning and she said no no we
did something else we did something
called visibility filter it's like well
uh well what what exactly uh what
exactly did you think Shadow Banning
meant if it didn't mean visibility
filtering uh I.E the throttling of
traffic the secret throttling of traffic
to accounts based on their political
Viewpoint so in any event you know we
didn't even know about Shadow Banning in
a conclusive proven way that was the
first revelation of the Twitter files
that Twitter was engaged in this big
brother alike censorship and they
created very elaborate tools to label
accounts they didn't like and thereby
throttle traffic to them we then learned
that the f FBI had something like 80
agents flagging accounts that they
didn't like to be reviewed by by
Twitter's trusted safety department
managed by you all Roth we learned that
Roth was meeting on a weekly basis with
the FBI and Department of Homeland
Security this sort of this intelligence
Community writ large and included the
CIA it included groups within the state
department so that came out we then
learned that the FBI had been pressuring
Twitter for information about Russian
collusion and Russian influence that
Twitter could not find I mean Joel Roth
I think to his credit in the Twitter
files kept saying guys we've looked at
this and there's nothing here these
accounts that you're flagging for us are
not Russian Bots they're just normal
accounts and then of course you had the
the ultimate expression of this was the
Hamilton 68
dashboard in which you had this group
for years tell us that that this this
dashboard they created 600 accounts was
a Russian influence operation it turned
out they were just ordinary accounts
ordinary Americans Twitter on the inside
knew this uh they knew that this
Hamilton 68 project which was quoted by
thousands of news articles as again
evidence of Russian disinformation they
knew that this was a complete hoax they
were saying that inside the company but
they didn't expose it so all of these
things were Revelations that came out in
the Twitter files and I don't think we
would have known any of it if if Elon
hadn't opened up these files and it's
wild because David you were sitting with
me right there at like 2 A.M we've got
Engineers on both sides of us with their
laptops I'm asking them every question I
could think of that was relevant and
they were gladly showing us everything
that they could they're not showing us
private you know user data information
but they basically opened up the books
and Elon said hey as long as it's true
then then go tell the people let me show
you this to that point this next clip of
Jim Jordan on the on the hunter Biden
laptop Mr chairman Mr Roth did the
government tell you that that the Biden
laptop story was fake
no sir they did not they tell you it was
hacked no sir they did not on October 14
2020 Twitter blocks the New York Post
story on the hunter Biden uh the New
York Post story on Hunter Biden and
suspends their account the night before
FBI special agent Elvis Chan sends you
an email the email says this heads up I
will be sending a teleporter link for
you to download 10 documents it's not
spam please confirm receipt when you get
it two minutes later 6 24 PM you respond
back received and downloaded thanks
what were those 10 documents
Twitter didn't give me access to my
laptop but special agent Chan has said
publicly and the FBI has confirmed that
those documents did not relate to Hunter
Biden and that's my recollection of that
what did they relate to
my interactions with agent Chan and with
the FBI almost entirely focused on what
the FBI called malign foreign
interference things like Russian troll
farms and Iranian involvement in the
elections not on any type of domestic
okay so let's give Joel Roth the benefit
of the doubt and say that what he just
said there is true it wasn't about the
hunter Biden laptop it happened to
happen the night before but clearly
there's been this ongoing conversation
with the FBI about Russian troll Bots
and everything else by the way when the
media thought that that was helping
Trump they were very interested in it
somehow they're not interested in this
story at all Viva lawyers private
companies what's going on here just to
add one thing to what Dave just said
earlier all the revelations now that
it's been revealed as well that the FBI
was remunerating or reimbursing or
compensating Twitter for their time in
the order of three some odd million
dollars peanuts you know probably in the
grand scheme of things but you know
operating now at the remuneration of but
it's beyond interference it's
infiltration see Twitter was nothing
more than an arm of intelligence CIA FBI
whatever you want to call it they had
been infiltrated and were not acting at
the behest of but in conjunction with as
an extension of the body
um and it's I mean it it crosses the
line but I one thing that's amazing I
I'm convinced Elon had to have known
about this because it's impossible to
explore the bot issue without stumbling
across this issue which is intimately
related to the Bots Russian Bots Etc I I
want to give Elon like the benefit of
the doubt here or even maybe impute a
lot of intention that might not exist I
think he knew it when he bought it and
this was the plan to blow the lid off it
all along otherwise uh you know
reimburse it take it back and give me my
42 billion dollars please sax real quick
before I let Marissa jump in do you want
to comment on that I mean do you have
any do you think that he kind of had the
feeling like I can't answer conclusively
what he knew or didn't know but I no I I
think that the Twitter files was a
revelation to all of us and and just
remember the way that happened is that
Elon brought in these journalists uh
Barry Wise Michael schellenberger Matt
taibi and gave them access to uh company
emails and Company slack channels and
using the techniques of investigative
reporters they went out and and dug all
this stuff up I don't think he would
have had access to to this generally
speaking before the the acquisition
um
but uh but can we go back to to the to
the video here for a second uh I just
want to unpack what what happened here
what happened is what Jim Jordan is
referring to is that the FBI had a tool
called teleporter which was a tool where
they could convey information basically
emails or written documents to Twitter
or to Executives of social media
companies and those documents would then
disappear after some period of time
after 10 days or whatever it is so
what's going on is that the FBI is
engaged in conveying secret
instructions to social media companies
about what they want to have happen and
there's no way for the public to know
about this I mean now this goes a Step
Beyond classification where you know
normally with classified documents maybe
at some point in time they could become
Declassified here the documents are
actually disappearing and I think Jim
Jordan is right to ask what exactly is
the government up to here that they need
to provide employees of social media
companies are engaged in you know trust
and safety which is censorship
what do they need to provide that's so
sensitive that it disappears you got to
give this Chad guy some credit for
putting it in an email what he was doing
related to The Disappearing things
Marissa I think what this all boils down
to though is Will anything happen it is
nice to see that the Republicans are
doing the right thing for a change but
we've all seen these things right we've
seen Ted Cruz Grill the hell out of Jack
Dorsey and and as David said before
basically Dorsey lied about Shadow
Banning and just used another phrase or
whatever do you think anything actually
comes of it and what do you think should
come of it that's exactly the point I
was going to make well I think that
Twitter being free or now is certainly a
relief to us certainly as uh those of us
here at prairieu but it's it's not the
first time that we're seeing real
concrete evidence of either Shadow
Banning or censorship coming from these
big tech companies I mean we've sued
YouTube our case got thrown out uh We've
shown many screenshots and evidence on
Facebook where we would post a a video
to our millions of followers on Facebook
and we would get two or three views on
them and so there was obvious Shadow
Banning we have communication both with
YouTube and with Facebook where they
have notified us that they will be
Shadow Banning us for several days and
that is because we're labeled as
misinformation well who determined that
the government that the government and
so when we have shown evidence we have
seen nothing we have seen no results and
no change and so my frustration is look
I mean we can all celebrate right that
Twitter is now free and obviously
incredibly grateful to what Elon Musk
and many others have done we finally can
advertise again on Twitter which we
couldn't for many many years but now
what now what is the government I mean
we know the left is not going to secede
power because this is exactly what
they're looking for will the Republicans
grow enough uh what it what do you say
here men what calls you can say balls
it's the Internet it's okay
actually fight for for the freedom of
speech that they promise that they're
going to fight for when they're running
for elections I mean that is really what
we need to see and I think that a big
question is section 230 section 230
allows these big companies to have the
cake and eat it too and I understand
where it came from and why it was
written in 1996 which feels like a very
long time ago certainly in the world of
the internet but it gives them all of
this protection and frankly they've
taken advantage of it and I think those
are some of the next steps we have
enough evidence now what right exactly
now what David let me give you the last
word on this since you're in on this
with Elon I mean do you do you feel that
he's ready to just keep going with all
of this and he'll keep you know fixing
it as much as they keep trying to
destroy it
well I think what Elon has done here is
an unprecedented Act of corporate
transparency where he's just basically
thrown open company emails and slack
channels to these investigative
reporters and that he's let them go find
out what happened and I don't think
there's been another company that's
that's ever done anything this
transparent the media is always talking
about the need for corporate
transparency and but here you don't see
them praising it or even covering it and
I think the reason is because it's it's
exposing something they don't like uh
which is Big text complicity in in
censorship
um of basically their of of basically
Democrats political enemies so this is
the last thing they want to expose I I
just want to make one other comment
about FBI involvement here the whole
reason why I think this is newsworthy
and why there should be Congressional
hearings is because of the FBI's
involvement remember this panel is
called the the it's the committee on on
government weaponization it's the
so-called Church committee 2.0 it's the
involvement of the FBI in the hunter
Biden laptop story that makes it
relevant it's not just uh it's not just
Executives or a private company who are
making these decisions because they're
they're political bias if it was just
that I don't think there would be that
much it still wouldn't be right but
there wouldn't be as much to investigate
the the manner in which though the FBI
influenced Twitter is is really
interesting I don't think that it's a
it's a clear-cut case of the FBI
ordering Twitter to do something it was
much more subtle than that what what
actually happened is that over a course
of many months the FBI influenced
Twitter by basically priming you all
Roth they told Joel Roth that there was
going to be a Russian Hack and leak
operation close to the election that
there would be Russian disinformation
and specifically it would involve Hunter
Biden and so Roth in other contexts has
testified under oath that he was primed
by the FBI to be on the lookout for a
Russian Hack and leak story and that is
why he he has previously testified that
they jumped on it and and basically
engaged in in censorship now at this
committee mysteriously you saw in that
clip with with Jim Jordan you all Roth
had just mysteriously forgotten about
that you know his previous testimony
about this point uh and and that and
that that is the thing that the
Republicans really need to drill in on
is where where did this FBI pre-bunking
operation come from this in was it you
know it's an awfully big coincidence
that the FBI was telling all these
social media companies be on the lookout
for a phony story about Hunter Biden uh
you know and Hunter Biden in Ukraine
that's an awfully big coincidence uh and
they even said it be on the lookout for
close to the election you know roughly
in October so how was it that the FBI
came to be involved in influencing
social media companies to think about a
story about Hunter Biden that way a
story that we now know was completely
true yeah actually let's stick with this
for a second because I think you're
making a really good point this this
priming idea which is seen seems to me
is kind of like a mafia tactic by the
FBI it's not like walking in there
and demanding the money today demanding
all the answers today it's just showing
up and going hey we're around and you're
kind of going to do what we want you to
do uh on the legal front yeah it's a
psyop um you know Dave here just can I
just one more thing that was really
creepy that came out of these hearings
that Michael schellenberger has has
written about is that a few weeks before
the New York Post came out with this
story there was a a um there was a
meeting at the Aspen Institute in which
Joel Roth attended and other trust and
safety Executives social media attended
and the Aspen Institute ran what they
called a tabletop exercise for these
social media companies in which they
were basically asked to game out sort of
war game out what would you do if there
was an October surprise in which a
Russian you know hack and dump operation
involving Hunter Biden came out and not
just involving Hunter by Hunter Hunter
Biden's activities in Ukraine working
for barisma literally this was the
exercise it happened three weeks before
the New York Post story came out the
person who runs the Aspen Institute is a
politically connected Democrat and the
Republicans on the committee were asking
you all Roth well don't you think this
is an awfully big coincidence and his
only explanation was yeah I guess it was
a coincidence this had nothing to do
with how I thought about uh the the New
York Post story when it came out but
this obviously was one element along
with the FBI and intelligence community
pre-briefing
uh Joel Roth and other social media
Executives for months about a potential
story involving Hunter Biden and this
primed them to later censor that story
so it was a very elaborate operation
that appears to one it was an operation
to influence these Tech Executives and
that is really the thing to get to the
bottom of is how did that happen and was
it really just a coincidence because
it's an awfully big coincidence
it's beyond priming I mean this is like
the mafia showing up and saying you have
a lovely social media company here it
would be a shame if something happens to
it it's it's priming or it's basically
threatening and it's an iteration of the
wrap up smear like what they're
basically doing is getting the media
companies or the tech companies to do
what they want them to do by planting
the seed there and then running with it
afterwards so they can pan an open
letter saying it's Russian
disinformation or the hunter Biden
laptop has all the Hallmarks of Russian
disinformation the the same FBI uh you
know leaks phony stories about what PP
in in Russian hotels so that they can
then have Yahoo publish it so they can
then invoke it before the courts it's an
iteration of the wrap-up smear
information laundering or in this case
disinformation laundering and it just
shows the extent to which Twitter had
been acting as a de facto branch of the
intelligence Community yeah David I
didn't want to move on but just just one
final point on this is remember
Zuckerberg when he was interviewed by
Rogan said the same thing that that you
all Roth had previously testified about
which is the FBI came to Facebook and
said be on the lookout for this type of
story it's also the same story that as
Viva just said there were 50 former
Security State officials who wrote a
letter with the New York Post story came
out claiming this was all Russian
disinformation so in other words you
have these former Security State
officials in their letter maintain this
line about Russia's information and you
have active FBI officials claim that it
was Russian information and you have
former FBI official Jim Baker inside of
Twitter basically leading the charge
saying it's Russian information how did
they all synchronize on the same story
it's one thing to synchronize on a story
when that story is true but when that
story is a lie when it's false we now
know this was not Russian's information
this all came off of Hunter Biden's
laptop but yet they all synchronized on
this lie here you know what let's say
let's actually continue with this
because I think this is what everyone on
on is is on everyone's mind so we're
going to drop the we were going to do
something about Trump and DeSantis we're
just going to let that go at the end
we'll do a little more on State of Union
in a minute but Marissa to David's point
the the sort of lie laundering I am I am
absolutely obsessed with this how these
lies work through the system and somehow
get to the New York Times and the
anonymous sources and that they're all
kind of in on it together
right you talk about Mafia lying in
threats how do we talk about censorship
without talking about the fact Checkers
the fact Checkers sound like a small
thing but it's actually a massive thing
and I'll I'll share an experience here
that we've had at prageru so we produce
content there is a company called
newsguard News Guard claims that there
are the Arbiters of truth right they get
to determine what is misinformation and
what is information that is allowed out
there when we produce content on what
they label as misinformation they label
prageru and daily wire and federal
Federalists and all these other
companies with this rating as if we are
making fake news and of course they'll
give CNN and New York Times and those
who behave according to their standards
they'll get a great a great rating now
why is this important we wouldn't even
care about newsguard we track down where
does the money come from who are the
supporters of newsguard we found that
750 000 was wired to News Guard from the
Department of Defense and so when News
Guard applies pressure on media
companies like ours and we receive
threatening emails from newsguard saying
why did you post this about covid why
did you post this about the lockdowns
questioning us and pressuring us to take
down content that they that they don't
like that is very very fishy and we know
that News Guard partners with these tech
companies they they partner with
Facebook they partner with many other
tech companies and so how do how can we
say that there is no government
involvement when there is actually
Financial wires coming out of the
government into these fact-checking
companies and the fact-checking
companies have Partnerships with the
with the tech companies they found this
very clever loophole to use government
intervention and pressure media
companies to comply right and to viva's
point earlier we now know that the
government paid 2 Twitter over three
million dollars to because they were
using their own employees to look into
some of this stuff one of the things
that that David and I found out when we
were at Twitter was that when I was
banned in July of 21 for saying that
vaccines were not working as promised
and mandates and boosters were coming
and all this stuff uh that they they
unbanned me a day later but the the
depression in the algorithm related to
my account that stayed they didn't know
that until
just a couple weeks ago David since
you're the SAS guy on this on the
software part of this related to Big
tech companies I'm actually sympathetic
that they need ways to take down content
in other words if someone does put uh
child porn which apparently nobody cared
about on Twitter until Elon took over
now he's actually doing something about
it and suddenly they care but the point
is they need some mechanisms to take
some things down but it seems like
almost an impossible job right at this
point because of the way the government
then sort of takes advantage of that
well everybody agrees that there needs
to be some level of content moderation
even if it's you know just taking down
child porn for example everybody agrees
that needs to come down I think most
people agree that hate speech should
come down or or violence or graphic
content the problem is that what happens
is that in order to facilitate that
content moderation these big tech
companies create tools and then once the
tools exist they can be hijacked and so
we first thought that these tools have
been hijacked by just highly political
and biased employees of these companies
now we're finding out that those
employees have had extensive
Communications with the FBI and
intelligence community and the
intelligence Community has been flagging
content for them to take down to the
point where like you said the government
was reimbursing millions of dollars of
employees time that's how much they were
using them you know they had over 80 FBI
agents involved in in this
um in this operation so what we saw is
that tech companies start with let's say
a valid need to engage in some content
moderation but they so that so then they
create these powerful tools and the
tools then get usurped and hijacked or
influenced by really powerful actors who
are behind the scenes that's why it's
wild what we learned at Twitter because
you know Jack says no we don't Shadow
band They testify oh we don't Shadow
band or whatever phrase they want to use
for it but as I tweeted out it was like
the whole system was designed to Shadow
yeah in a bizarre sense yeah I mean
exactly I think that there's no way that
you can defend that statement because
there as we found out there were if you
look at the tools that were created
there were flags that said do not
amplify in other words you could label
an account with do not amplify and it
would de-boost or throttle the amount of
traffic they would get in their feed
from people who are following them they
were first a flag for do not appear in
search there is a flag for do not Trend
so they could very precisely control how
much traffic you got and where you
appeared on the site and and of course
the the word Shadow here is key which is
they were not informing anybody about
when a label was implied to you you were
never informed I mean obviously when you
were kicked out of your account and
suspended if you were banned you found
out about that but anything short of an
overt ban they never told you about that
was the whole point of Shadow Banning
that's what that word means is that
you're not informed about actions taking
on your account to thrall your traffic
and what we found is they were doing
that and they had very elaborate tools
to do that yeah and and they did not
they deny it and then when it comes out
later then yoel Roth refers back to some
tweet from a while back says see we told
you we were doing it but we used word it
was it was um and then when you
criticize Joel Roth for having done that
then it becomes like the internet
mobbing you all Roth and the victimizer
has become the victims but just to
highlight one thing about the um you
know those 50 some odd Intelligence
Officers pending the letter that the
Russian the hunter Biden laptop had all
the earmarks of Home Russian
disinformation they knew at the time it
was true the FBI had had it for over a
year since 2019 they knew it was a lie
they're priming when the FBI shows up at
your door like Zuckerberg said in his in
his clip with Rogan you take that very
seriously because like Chuck Schumer
said they have six ways from Sunday of
getting back at you so this is this is
not Pride this is FBI knocking on your
door and telling you what to do but in a
manner formulated as a question all
right one one more on this then which is
that on on the First Amendment front of
this I actually spoke to a couple fairly
well-known lawyers about what actual
repercussions there are if the
government infringes on your first
amendment rights meaning if I tweet
something out and then about vaccines
let's say which happened and then the
government forces a private company to
take that down is that actually a
violation of of my first amendment
because it's government coercion and
what is your recourse and basically
every lawyer that I talk to that are
First Amendment lawyers they're they're
all pretty much in agreement that you
know you'd have to know exactly the
details of who sent the email and all
that but in essence it is a First
Amendment uh violation but there's
pretty much no recourse like you can't
sue the government in essence if
anything you could maybe get the
government to apologize but that's
pretty much it that's kind of depressing
isn't it Marissa so they can just keep
doing this over and over and the worst
thing that happens is some like half
nitwit mid-level management guy from the
government comes out and goes ah we're
sorry we did that I mean isn't that
amazing these huge companies just get to
apologize and just say oh sorry you know
it was one of our little employees we
didn't mean we didn't know that they
were actually causing a complete change
in America's election we had no idea or
the executive suddenly have amnesia I
mean if they really have nothing to hide
why do they have severe memory loss you
know yeah so so Dave just on this point
I mean there there is no I guess private
right of action or there's no recourse
in addition to that if you look at the
emails that were sent from Elvis Chan to
you all Roth that came out in the
Twitter files what you see is that
they're very careful to always say up
front that we're flagging these accounts
for possible violations of your policies
so I think we just should be clear about
the nature of this influence which is
the government never explicitly orders
Twitter to engage in censorship because
I think these government officials know
they'll be a blatant violation of the
first amendment that what they claim to
be doing is flagging accounts that they
say are in violation of Twitter's own
rules separately in Washington you get
pressure from the Judiciary Committee
and these other Congress uh men and
Senators Representatives constantly
pressuring Twitter to modify its terms
of use to expand the categories that are
not allowed to create these categories
of misinformation so essentially it's
this it's um it's this two-handed
operation where Washington is pressuring
the elected representatives are
pressuring social networks to expand the
categories of censorship and then the
FBI or in terms Community is flagging
posts under their own rules so they
basically have the Fig Leaf of saying
well we didn't order you to do this and
I think you have to understand that it's
again it's more of an influence game or
a pressure game rather than an overt
ordering and I think it's just it's
important to understand that if you're
an executive at one of these tech
companies and the FBI or the CIA comes
to you and says you know gee these these
accounts are a problem you're under
enormous pressure yep so basically do
what they want I mean nobody wants to
defy the FBI and you can see the
deliberations within Twitter I mean I
think to you all Ross Credit there are
certain times within the Twitter files
he expresses gee you know they're asking
us to do something you know they're
they're putting pressure on us to censor
these accounts there's nothing wrong
with these accounts you know we should
push back on this but what you see is
that he gets overruled there's too much
pressure on them to basically just
comply as opposed to defy this
incredibly powerful law enforcement
agency of our government and by the way
that's why we've played on this show
I've probably played this clip 50 times
maybe more than that the clip from what
about a year and a half ago now we're
gen saki at one of the press conferences
says we flag posts for Facebook and I
always relate it back to me if I was
getting a call every now and again from
the administration just saying hey Dave
we're watching your show you've been
talking an awful lot about that thing
I might start talking about something
else so that that is the mafia tactic
but let's just do one other topic that's
actually sort of related to all this
because we've been talking about sort of
how these lies get laundered through the
system obviously the State of the Union
was on Tuesday night and I was
fascinated while watching this because
you know one of the the memes these days
is that we're all watching the same
movie and having wildly different
reactions to things and I saw people
that I respect that that saw something
very different than I saw so I want to
show you one clip of Biden and the way
that our politicians and then the media
uh launder the lies disrupted our supply
chains and Putin's unfair and brutal war
in Ukraine disrupted energy supplies as
well as Food Supplies blocking all that
grain in Ukraine but we're a better
position than any country on Earth right
now but we have more to do but here at
home inflation is coming down here at
home gas prices are down a dollar fifty
from their Peak food inflation is coming
down not fast enough but coming down
inflation has fallen every month for the
last six months well take-home pay has
gone up
additionally over the last two years a
record 10 million Americans apply to
start new businesses 10 million
and by the way
every time
okay so I think everyone watching gets
how virtually everything he said there
was a lie or a confusion yes inflation
has come down a tiny bit after
skyrocketing yes gas prices have come
down a tiny bit after skyrocketing uh
the wage that he's talking about is not
going up as fast as inflation so you're
still losing money uh and they did put a
whole bunch of people out of work
because of kovid the policy that he
still has going uh till May uh Marissa
were you pulling your hair out during
this thing or what well I was actually
learning quite a bit from him because
what you know I ran a non-profit so what
maybe what I'll do is require my entire
staff 150 people and then in three
months I'll go back to the board and say
look at me I'm so amazing I just hired
150 people
great productivity so you know there's
quite a bit to learn from our uh
president not in a good way uh was I
pulling my hair out I mean every I I can
dissect every sentence there and pull my
hair out I mean the energy part is just
abysmal as well the first thing he did
in office was cut the Keystone Pipeline
and make America you know essentially
poorer
right and Viva he also seemingly all he
has to do for people to basically say
it's good is not fall off the stage
right I mean basically his as long as
his eye doesn't explode which happened
during one of the debates pretty much
everybody's like my God he's still got
it he he I I feel bad making this
observation but he reminds me his facial
expressions remind me of my grandmother
when she was like 102 years old it's not
normal it's not healthy thing yeah um
and it's like it's people who have seen
it know what it looks like but the lies
it's everybody needs to read or Listen
to George Orwell's 1984 when you have
the government talking about how prices
have gone down rations have gone up
first of all having gone down from
rocket high prices because of
incompetence is not a success it's a
mitigation of failure uh and then at the
end of the day you don't even know if
any of it's true but the energy and
Marissa touched on it on the one end
cutting the Keystone Pipeline which
pissed Canada off as well but also
talking about how Russia's interfering
with energy while allegedly according to
um oh geez I forgot his game now someone
will help me the the journalist who just
broke this covered the story while
they're allegedly sabotaging the north
stream pipelines to Germany everything
they accused their enemies of doing is
what they themselves have done it's pure
confession through projection yes I
quote you on that line all the time uh
sex you've been talking a ton about
about Ukraine and going on Tucker and
you've been very outspoken on on all in
podcasts and everything it seems to me
that this thing keeps getting escalated
partly so that no matter what happens
here domestically Biden can kind of
blame Russia for it
well yeah you saw in that clip that he
blamed uh Russia for inflation this is a
rehash of the so-called Putin price hike
which was one of their lines when
um when uh you know to basically try and
fob off the blame for inflation the
problem is that inflation was already at
something like seven percent when Putin
invaded Ukraine the Ukraine Invasion
certainly didn't make anything better it
made things worse and I would lay some
fault for that with Biden's refusal to
engage in serious diplomacy Before the
War I do think that the war was
preventable if we had used diplomacy and
we didn't I do believe that I mean I
think one place where Trump is right
there's a lot of things I don't like
about what he says he's not my preferred
candidate but I do think he's right that
if Trump had been in office I don't
think we would have had this war so
there is some blame to allocate there
but just just to go back on the the
inflation point
um it's not it's not all because of
Putin what happened is that the
administration spent way too much money
we had trillions of dollars of
additional spending in the first two
years of this Administration and that
set off inflation like a rocket and
Larry Summers warned them that it would
do that and then they maintained this
party line that it was transitory and it
turned out not to be so we're all
Downstream of those decisions that were
made uh very early in the binding
Administration yeah and by the way you
can't just blame another foreign leader
for all of your problems meaning it's
your job to mitigate those things so if
there's a war across the world it's your
job to go okay how do we make sure that
doesn't affect our Economic Policy here
you're trying to get in go yeah no first
of all Seymour Hirsch was the was the
journalist I mean who broke who wrote
the story but um wasn't there also the
the fact that they actively
um deterred uh diplomacy they said but
don't sit down don't negotiate I mean
they've exacerbated this conflict at
every step of the of the way and it's
because it's easier to govern through
emergency than it is to govern through
stability and the more the more chaos
overseas the more they can blame
everything the Putin price hike I'd love
to see the think tank that came up with
that term
but uh yeah there were a couple of
amazing stories that came out in Ukraine
just the last couple weeks so so number
one is the Seymour Hearst story which uh
in which he contends and and really lays
out and proves that the bombing of
Nordstrom was an American covert
American operation if that is true that
is a significant escalation of this war
it represents a direct attack an act of
War perpetrated by the United States on
Russia that is something that Biden
promised at the beginning of this
conflict would never happen is that we
would not get directly involved so and
and you know they're trying to dismiss
you more Hurst but he's a bullet
surprise winning journalists who's
previously exposed the my massacre in
Vietnam and he exposed the Abu ghraib
prison abuses during the Iraq War so
this is certainly a journalist with I
think a history of major expose about
um you know covert military activity so
so I think that that was Story number
one story number two is that naftali
Bennett gave an interview
in the past couple of weeks in which he
said that this goes back to March of
last year he was a mediator trying to
find a peace deal in the first month of
the war and what came out of his
comments is that the administration had
no interest in that deal uh one of the
translators used the word block another
one just said that there's a debate over
the translation but the bottom line is
that the administration threw cold water
on a deal this was very similar to a
report that came out about the Istanbul
peace process that happened in April of
last year in which Boris Johnson was
reported to flown in and basically
through cold water in the process told
zelinski that the West did not want to
negotiate with Putin and wanted to
confront Putin so you have now multiple
stories about the West really the bind
Administration not wanting to engage in
negotiation once the war started they
did not seriously engage in negotiation
before the war back in January the
central demand of the Russians was that
we take NATO expansion off the table we
adamantly refused to do that that
basically then was one of the major
factors that led to the invasion so I
think you've seen here that the
administration just has had no interest
in shutting down this war and preventing
this war and instead they keep
escalating this war and you saw as well
they they recently decided to send
Abram's tanks so they keep upping our
level of involvement upping the level of
sophistication of the weapons that we're
providing and now if you believe the
Seymour her story getting directly
involved this is an incredibly dangerous
situation and the Administration has
never explained what exactly is the
vital American interest that compels us
to risk getting into War 3 with Russia
which has something like six thousand
nuclear weapons I mean there's so much
there because there's plenty of video of
Biden when he was campaigning saying
that they're never going to turn on the
pipeline and then suddenly the pipeline
blows up so that would kind the lend
itself to that but Marissa to this point
of like the the slow escalation of this
thing like okay now we're going to give
them a few more tanks now we're going to
train a few more people we're going to
send them some more planes I mean first
off at some point it does strike me that
we actually are at War right if you just
fund everything at some point you are
technically at War I think
um but even beyond that to David's point
he's got nukes 14 more tanks are not
going to end this freaking thing
you know I think the main issue is that
he's taking advantage of this situation
that is happening in Russia and Ukraine
to blame some of the policies that he
has made here uh and are impacting
Americans and sadly Americans are not
educated and not aware and they we've
been manipulated we Americans think that
the reason gas prices are higher and
energy is higher here in the United
States is because of the war in Russia
and Ukraine and that could not be a
bigger lie every single when you're
paying your bills and you're thinking
that that is because of something that
is happening in Russia I mean he's just
using it as a way to really distract
Americans the reason we're paying more
in energy here is because we have
frankly stupid policies that are causing
us to be more and more dependent on on
whatever other terrorist regimes and so
you know whether we get involved in the
war or not I mean the fact that he spent
all this time talking I I the first my
first reaction when I was watching the
State of the Union was I felt like I was
an a in a Twilight Zone and B you know
really are you even speaking to
Americans are you speaking to the issues
that we actually care about and and so
his way of speaking to the issues that
America cares about which is why is my
food basket so expensive why is energy
so expensive is to actually distract us
and and have us feel like we have to be
involved in this Russian Ukraine war in
order to solve our energy problems here
or whatever you know blue yellow squares
that people post on social media to feel
like they're you know they're they're
part of the solution I I think it that
is the bigger problem is this real
disconnect with what Americans not only
want but what we actually need well to
that point uh the whole purpose of me
doing this show at this point is just to
like lift a little bit of the fog from
the media nonsense related to all of
this because I agree it's like people
watch these things now and it's so
disconnected from their reality and I
don't know how long the that can hold
I'll give you each one final word Viva
I'm going to quote George Orwell again
the war was not meant to be won it was
meant to be perpetual and it wasn't just
Joe Biden who said if Russia invades
Ukraine one way or another that
Nordstrom pipeline will come to an end
how are you going to do that it's in
Germany we'll make it happen Victoria
Newland said it almost verbatim CIA
gives Germany the heads up the summer
before that something might happen uh
but yeah Seymour Hersh is a conspiracy
theorist and they've categorically
denied that article they deny it then
they admit it
um or sorry they deny it then they spin
it then they admit it because the truth
cannot long be hidden
David final thought yeah well just to go
back to your point that we are directly
involved in in this war we may not be
pulling the triggers but we're providing
the weapons the more and more advanced
weapons we've appropriated over 100
billion dollars we've trained Ukrainian
soldiers on how to use those weapons
including on American soil we provided
the intelligence to paint Targets on the
backs of Russian generals you had
Administration officials bragging to the
New York Times The Washington Post that
our intelligence helped sink the mosfa
the Russian Flagship you've had
um you know stories now in the in the
New York Post sorry the New York Times
The Washington Post where uh describing
how it was American generals who planned
the successful Ukrainian counter-attack
last fall so we are deeply deeply
involved and you heard precious little
from Biden during the State of the Union
to explain
why exactly America is involved other
than very vague generalities and I think
he has not done enough to prepare the
American people for the level of risk
that we're taking and I can only hope
that this that we wrap up our
involvement in this war soon because it
is continually escalating Marissa now
the ultimate Challenge to you and us on
a positive note considering David just
said World War III is coming
or results
if you're able to watch this
and you will realize that you're being
lied to stop waiting for other people to
do the fighting for you do something
about it don't rest on your laurels you
know people are not going to do your own
fighting go educate other people and get
involved I mean you might not be able to
buy Twitter but there's certainly
something you can do other than just
complain
you need only have a mirror you did it
Marissa well done uh thank you guys this
was really like fully fully enjoyed this
and it's it's really it's why I do this
show so thanks to you guys I'm going to
continue solo for a little bit have a
great weekend everybody and uh yeah I'm
bringing my friend Bob on bringing a
childhood friend uh my childhood friend
Bob is going to now come on the show for
our local subscribers and tell me
everything I did wrong today that's what
we're gonna do if you want to join us
for that you can join us at
reubenreport.locals.com let me just say
real quick though uh I think you know we
dumped the third segment there we were
going to do something on some of Trump's
attacks on DeSantis and and some of
desantis's response on that and I
actually felt that the first segment
especially was so important this is
what's on people's minds if we cannot
figure out what is going on here and why
our reality is so disconnected from what
the media shows us and big Tech we are
just going to continue that slow descent
to hell so I hope uh that you all felt
that that was a worthy uh 50 minutes or
so which is longer than we usually do on
these round tables so if you want to
join us now and watch Bob rip me apart
and go through the rest of the week's
nonsense I said he was a childhood
friend he was a friend from my stand-up
days great funny guy Bob's going to join
us from New York of all places we got a
guy in New York to rip me apart uh join
us right now at
reubenreport.locals.com we'll be there
in about 12 seconds
[Music]
foreign